If a patient has M-steed bar virus and heavy metals in the past and currently as
cancer, should the test for M-steed bar and heavy metals be run?
Pub, maybe, so M-steed bar virus, understand the tests for M-steed bar viruses, so if you're
going to run an M-steed bar virus test, you have to run a test that tests for, let me type
this in here so you guys can understand this. You have to test for IgG antibodies and for
IgM antibodies. So, IgG antibodies test for past exposure, so if you look at a past M-steed
bar virus tested and showed high IgG antibodies, that just means you had exposure to M-steed
bar in the past. You could have had it as a child and you have no current M-steed
bar virus, but you still have antibodies for M-steed bar virus. That's a good thing. You want
antibodies for different viruses and bacteria, but that says that you were exposed to it in
the past. You shouldn't be treating it if you have elevated IgG antibodies. If you have IgM
antibodies, that means you have a current infection of M-steed bar or anything, so if you're
testing anything in your testing, an antibody test for something, IgG antibodies tell you
that you had exposure to it in the past. It doesn't tell you how bad that exposure was,
doesn't tell you that you were really sick of it from it in the past. You could have just
been exposed to it, never got sick and developed antibodies. That does not mean you're sick
now and it does not mean that you need to treat it if you have IgG antibodies. If you have
IgM antibodies, then you should treat for that, then you should run the rife, then you
should treat it nutritionally, then you should depend on what diseases, if it's a bacterial
infection or whatever, maybe use antibiotics, then you should treat an active infection.
This is past infection. This is an active infection. It's many times different doctors will run
an M-steed bar virus test, in particular, and see a high elevated IgG antibodies, so
you have M-steed bar, we need to treat it. That's just not true. You want to look at that.
Can you run these tests? I think it's valuable to run any tests. I think all tests are valuable.
We should have a discussion about this. Heavy metals. Everybody's going to have elevated
heavy metals and some people are going to have more delirious effects of heavy metal exposure.
Some people are going to have increased heavy metal exposure and overwhelm their detox pathways.
With everything, you're just trying to start slow. You've got to go back to the 7 phase of
detox. You've got to walk through 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1, before you start pulling stuff out of
the tissues too quickly. I don't like doing everything all at once. We want to clear out
the body, get this person doing coffee at events, get this person detoxing, get them using
the rife, and then we can have a discussion of what's that deeper step we could go. That's
why I created all those courses, so you could continue to go deeper with your health. Do I have
an autoimmune disease? Is that what's hindered my immune response? Is ability to kill my cancer
or should I deal with that? Do I have heavy metals? Do I have other things that I need to
deal with that taking me to that deeper level? Now it's going to improve my health. I'm
all for running these tests. The problem with heavy metal testing, just a side note of this.
Heavy metal testing is difficult. You could do hair analysis for heavy metal testing, particularly
accurate. It doesn't tell us where we're at right now. If you had heavy metals in your blood,
that would just mean you have an acute heavy metal toxicity. That should be run in the hospital,
if this person gets some stroke-like symptoms after a possible exposure of arsenic,
they'll run a blood heavy metal test, and then they will do IV chelation, hopefully right away,
to try to chelate that under their blood. If you've had heavy metal exposure over time,
it's not going to stay in the blood and it's going to be in the tissue. So blood testing for heavy
metal really doesn't make any sense from a functional test. Then there is what's called a push test.
The push test is where you take access chelated agents like DMSA and EDTA, which will pull a lot of
heavy metals out of the tissues. Then you do a 24-hour urine test. So it's a push 24-hour urine test
to test for heavy metals. That's the most accurate way to see how much heavy metals you have
in the tissues. The problem is it's really not good to do health-wise. It's a horrible health test
as far as I don't detect whether you have heavy metals. It'll satisfy your curiosity whether
you do, but it could make you really super sick. So I do not ever recommend doing the provocation test.
And that's what a lot of functional medicine doctors do. You could really make a person really sick.
The truth is that we are all exposed to heavy metals, and you don't really, in my opinion,
you don't really need to test for them, because if you're supporting all the phases of detoxification,
you will be pulling these things out. So there are some better tests to run for other things
other than heavy metals. There's a really good test by Mosaic, but it's on hold right now,
till I think the end of, because they're updating the test, the end of July, it's supposed to,
first part of August, it's supposed to be up and running again, and that's going to test for
like 150 different toxins. That's what I'm excited that that one comes out. Right now, I really like
the glyphosate test, and there's several other tests that they have that I like for testing toxicity.
And again, you know, throughout the years of taking care of people from a functional medicine
perspective, it's always really good to look at tests because it gives a person some motivation to move
forward. Most of my cancer patients don't need motivation. And I say, I want you to take this key
later or whatever, because it comes up in kinesiology testing. They don't need something on paper,
black and white to be motivated to do it. So I don't typically have to resort to running all these
different labs, because they get to be pricey, when we could just do treat as if, because we know
we have heavy metals, we have to detoxify, we know we have these things. I like to get somewhat of
a picture as much as we possibly can, but I do recommend hair analysis sometimes. It's just,
it's sometimes good, it's nice for a patient to see, I'll just tell you, it's just not all that
accurate. So that's the only thing I don't like about that. So heavy metal testing is just, is kind of,
you know, you know, hair analysis is not very accurate. Blood is not going to show it all. The
push test is just not good at all, health-wise. So we kind of have to resort to kinesiology or
just assumption that we all have heavy metals that we have to deal with. And you certainly can't do
chelation therapy, heavy chelation therapy if you're a bunch, a metal in your mouth, mercury fillings
and such. So you're limited to what you could do with that. But the MC bar and the other different
latent virus test, you want to make sure you run a test that does IGG and IGM, the ones that we have
in that I put in room to do both of those. So, but if you are going to see a local function of
as a doctor concurrently with what you're doing us, you might be good to pass by me what test that
doctor wants to run just so we're not, you're not running something that's kind of frivolous.